I am Oh what is the most painful award
show to sit through everyone always says
oh there's so much fun it's such an
honor to be here but I know some of them
have to be painful for you guys hey guys
welcome to interviews under the
influence I'm Sophia Lacy with ET and
today we are playing five shots with
Florida Georgia line I have in my hand a
bunch of Real Talk questions here this
is where the real fun comes in these are
the drunk talk questions when you pull a
question from this tower if you do not
want to answer the question you are
going to have to take a shot if you do
play ball
then you're gonna force me to take a
shot first player to five shots loses
and today we are drinking old camp with
you so to start and tell me about how
you guys came up with old camp
well camp is the whiskey that we develop
this is a peach pecan flavor so a little
bit of Ford a little bit of Georgia
right there just something we're really
proud of we spent all last year
developing the flavor and the branding
and the bottle and all that man I'm
getting that one right there
real smooth whoo shag marry kill we've
got Bella and Louise Lucy and Ethel and
the Judds and I have to drink if I don't
answer you have to drink if you don't
answer a very good one boy say later
come on
I am Oh what is the most painful award
show to sit through everyone always says
oh there's so much fun it's such an
honor to be here but I know some of them
have to be painful freak you guys so
many award shows I don't want to name
the wrong one you got a check first yeah
that's fine no no no the fun ones
they're all fun I would say any award
show that you're hungover
that was a sneaky answer I don't know if
I'm gonna let that one fly
the correct answer what's your answer
don't answer don't not that age not that
answer okay I'll drink to it you guys
are not off to a good start here okay
well we'll give you a freebie here that
you do not need to drink for in your
video for may we all there's a pretty
heated fight theme what are you guys
most likely to fight about in real life
his house we're probably going to record
vocal back when we're home for two days
every month we really don't want to
leave the house what we want to write
songs so it's a give-and-take well write
one in the tree house right one to farm
get balanced no doubt dealer's choice
okay I have a couple questions here that
I tailored for you guys if you had to
replace your bandmate with a member of
one of the Backstreet Boys who would it
be and why mmm I'm gonna go with Nick is
the youngest so you know he's got more
longevity there I'm just kidding guys I
love all you guys
very cool all right well here we go yeah
or one in one right yeah who's keeping
track haha this is so mean who would you
rather die then collaborate with oh I'm
gonna probably drink to that and that's
that's that's just offensive I could
probably think of somebody but that just
means I'm just gonna drink Cheers cheers
to that
cheers to not being mean this one got
dealer's choice again all right your
breakout single Cruz has been certified
gold and platinum how much money have
you made off that song yeah I'm gonna
have to take a nice little citizen cap
money made that's a good place to be
read us your last text exchange with
Luke Bryan Jason Aldean or Tim McGraw
okay first we'll start with Jason even
though there is still no response
hahaha thanks again for having us
tonight bro great folks in good time
miss being on the road together y'all
sleep good but I know he misses us I can
tell I know he does another no response
this is to Luke yo low-key friend hang a
citizen after the award show no extras
just good friends
food and drinks on us can't wait
haha Luke kindly decline no well he was
there but snow spun we're more friends
still you know I knows me we're tied Wow
here we go thanks Tyler
alright I'm proud of you for playing
along with this I am just so everyone
knows I'm not drinking water this is
real whoa
that means someone's got a drink yeah
here we go mm-hmm I'm gonna answer this
one right there you go
have you ever gone on stage after a few
too many what happened
I'd say probably a couple years ago to
be honest yep I had a couple too many
but like a pro finish the show and pull
myself together are you you got a drink
yep yeah don't you forget T AB you want
to pick one from the rubble there
describe your most uncomfortable run-in
with another celebrity I actually have a
story for you I was in Rome with me and
my wife and a hotel I go across the
hallway to the pool Haley's still in the
gym working out and so is Owen Wilson
Haley's like Tyler you should tweet I
wouldn't Wilson and maybe just see if
he's a fan of country music and maybe he
just happens to want to hang out with us
and have a drink later and so I did I
got on Twitter I said what's up man
Tyler here Florida Georgia line happen
to be in the same hotel you're at in
Rome a few hours go by we're at lunch
Haley's check her Twitter he tweets me
back with a little wine glass that says
yes we're showering up getting all ready
I'm going to have a drink with Owen
listen tonight so we go down to the bar
sit there for about an hour he doesn't
show up so we go to the restroom on the
way out of the bar right before walking
to dinner I come out of the bathroom
sure enough here comes Owen Wilson
walking down the hallway so I'm like
well sup there is what's up he didn't
know me nor did he even have Twitter I
got catfished by Owen Wilson in Rome and
then he turned around and asked me what
band I was in again I told him Florida
Georgia line he said cool and then
walked on down the hallway it was quite
humiliating and embarrassing and I was
actually that guy
so thanks Owen Wilson and Tyler I'm good
for this guy right here
what is the most embarrassing thing on
your iPod for some reason I have the
song tootsie roll by the 69 boys I don't
know where that came from
but uh all right you guys are victorious
save us one yeah whoo
thank you guys so much for watching and
let me know in the comments below who do
you want to see do an interview under
the influence also you can reach me on
Twitter I am at Sophie Chalet see and be
sure to subscribe to ET on YouTube and
please please please always remember to
drink responsibly